actually we don't know when we have it
that's the great thing about it real
happiness is that which comes up right
out of your own cells where you kind of
let go striving for happiness you know
and in peak sexual experience peak
meditative experience delicious food
friendly conversation when you forget
about yourself and how unhappy and
miserable you are which you usually are
all the time all cramped up in some like
drive to do something get somewhere then
somehow your cells and your system and
your mind and your brain which is a very
sensitive ready to perceive aesthetic
experience and have a great time it's is
reaching out and realizing that the
universe is a place of blissful energy
and so that's when you're really happy
and you don't know it because you don't
pay attention to that you're engaged in
what you're doing you're lost in the
zone of even it could be just a
conversation with a loved one quality
time what we call you know which we
scheduled I can brief two seconds
between making money or running here and
there and that's what real happiness is
and you don't know it because you don't
pay attention to it the minute you try
to know it and say oh how happy am i how
good how much high-quality is this time
you immediately evaluated it's not good
enough and all I need well now I have to
leave five minutes from now so now that
ruins the next five minutes because I'm
going to be leaving after five so then
we'll start weeping instead of enjoying
being together this type of thing you
see so so that's the cure the key to
happiness is loving people enjoying your
life not worrying about a lot of things
letting your mind not live in some
fantasy in your mind about some other
thing that's going to be better and
appreciating what's in the moment that
is really what it is and you won't know
it when you have it but you will that's
when you'll have it you know it's a
variable lovely paradox life is very
paradoxical and that's what it is
we follow the cycles of negativity
because of our ignorance of what's
really going on and that ignorance is
not just personal it isn't like we
didn't learn enough in school it's like
the ignorance handed down in our
cultures telling us well you're
worthless for example especially in the
West the religion was like it was
misinterpreted Jesus is wonderful
teaching about the kingdom of God is
within you and there's like a special
Providence to the fall of every Sparrow
and they're like relax look at the
flowers in the field all this beautiful
stuff I wish they are by the way
thousands of rabbis in Jewish history
teaching the same beautiful vision and
he was a rabbi after all you know and
people you know the heart though Anglo
should remember that and and he we we've
been conditioned that's been distorted
into you're worthless and only God is
great and you know Jesus you look what
Jesus had to do for you and you know you
therefore get out and make some money or
do something cause you're so worthless
and then we look and then the nihlus
come along the scientists supposedly
liberating us from that and of course
the threat of eternal damnation in hell
by this like friendly huh and then they
say you're nothing they say you just die
you die whatever you know you're worth
so usually your 13 cents of cheap
chemicals I mean it so basically we're
told we're worthless and like therefore
naturally we want to justify our
existence and rush off and be famous or
make money or do something else you know
or even be a martyr and do something for
someone in some sort of present
breathing and not helpful way actually
and so so we have to wake up from that
and develop our critical wisdom and
intelligent